[Musique]
je
je suis ici pour la liberté
nous voulons simplement la liberté je
pense que tout le monde devrait se
joindre à nous aujourd'hui pour la
liberté du peuple
nous ne voulons pas obéir aux règles qui
nous ont été imposées ils nous imposent
comment penser comment nous comporter
il impose des mesures qui sont
dévastatrices pour notre peuple
nous ne voulons pas tolérer cela plus
longtemps nous devons leur donner un
délai jusqu'au auquel ils doivent abolir
toutes ces mesures nous voulons que la
vie revienne à la normale à ce qu'elle
était avant tout cela
[Musique]
tous
nouveautés mobiles
mais ne protestons pas contre le virus
ou contre les preuves médicales nous
protestons contre la restriction de la
liberté
cela ne signifie pas que l'abandon des
restrictions et déterminera les gens à
renoncer à leurs mesures de protection
personnelle mais les restrictions et les
mesures de protection ne doivent plus
être obligatoire
[Musique]